[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le journal de tv
78 nous sommes le jeudi 16 septembre
voici les titres
l'inauguration ce matin du foyer
d'accueil médicalisé de belleville cette
plateforme inter départementale entre
les yvelines et les hauts-de-seine est
installé aux mureaux elle est dédiée à
l'accueil d'adultes atteints de troubles
du spectre autistique ou de handicap
psychique
alors que les états généraux de la
justice sont annoncées pour l'automne
focus dans ce journal sur la formation
des avocats des magistrats notre invité
maryvonne caillibotte procureur de la
république de versailles nous parlerons
de la justice de demain elle nous
donnera sa vision sur le procès des
attentats du 13 novembre 2015 qui s'est
ouvert récemment et enfin vous le voyez
un des facteurs qui photographient les
habitants certains en plus de la
distribution quotidienne est du courrier
dans les yvelines ainsi at-elle depuis à
quelques jours des clichés pour un
projet artistique on le verra tout à
l'heure mené par yann arthus-bertrand
les plus belles prises seront exposées
au louvre et ce en 2022 dans ce journal
est également à suivre une fois que tu
sais c'est le film choc sur
l'environnement climat dit sur le
réchauffement climatique
une avant première est programmée à
demain vendredi à l'ugc vélizy et on en
parlera à la fin de ce journal
[Musique]
mais avant de développer ces titres le
déplacement de bruno le maire cet après
midi à saint germain en laye le ministre
de l'économie accompagné à du ministre
délégué aux pme alain griset est venu
rencontrer des chefs d'entreprise qui
des commerçants va peut être voir les
images s'affichent est au coeur de cette
table ronde le plan indépendant du
gouvernement annoncée par emmanuel
macron à la mi journée 20 mesures pour
plus de simplicité et plus de protection
pour les indépendants ils sont 3
millions en france elle nous reviendrons
plus longuement sur cette visite dans
l'émission 7 8 week-end demain vendredi
sur tv 78 un foyer d'accueil médicalisé
pour les personnes atteintes d'autisme
vient d'être inaugurée donc aux mureaux
un projet inter départementale menée par
les yvelines et les hauts-de-seine avec
l' agence régionale de santé l'objectif
prendre en charge et accompagner ces
personnes sans solution est les
précisions de justin brasier un foyer
d'accueil médicalisé inter
départementale vient d'être inauguré aux
mureaux ce jeudi 16 septembre
il permettra l'hébergement de 116
personnes en situation de handicap
atteinte de troubles du spectre
autistique ou de troubles psychiques à
la fois des unités avec des espaces y
compris cafétéria lieux de sociabilité
j'irai casier en autogestion où j'ai
vraiment tout est fait pour développer
l'autonomie de la personne et puis
d'autres unités qui sont pour des
personnes qui présentent des troubles
plus nette l'établissement ouvrira ses
portes le 4 octobre prochain un projet
qui répond à un besoin du territoire
dans les départements des yvelines et
des hauts-de-seine 400 personnes
seraient concernées par un manque de
prise en charge un plan d'accueil a été
défini pour éviter les départs en
belgique on est dans une situation de
moratoire aujourd'hui il n'ya plus
d'adultes qui sont envoyés en belgique
alors envoyés en belgique encore une
fois les adultes qui sont ils sont bien
accueillis mais ils sont pas à proximité
des familles et donc il répond
évidemment à ce besoin là d'accueil des
personnes présentant ces troubles
l'établissement est implantée sur le
site de belleville aux mureaux un
endroit stratégique qui s'inscrit dans
un pôle sanitaire et social on veut ici
faire un espèce de deux campus de santé
et donc ça nous paraissait logique dans
le cadre de cet aménagement de venir au
mur puis ya une logique d'aménagement du
territoire la vallée de seine
aujourd'hui est un territoire meurtri en
matière d'emploi et cet établissement va
créer des emplois il ya plus de 300
emplois qui vont être générés par
l'installation de cet établissement coût
total du projet 31 millions d'euros
nous allons ouvrir à présent une page
justice dans ce journal avec mon invité
maryvonne caillibotte bonsoir bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous est le procureur
de la république de versailles avec vous
on va parler justement de justice mais
plus précisément de la justice de demain
comment doit-elle évoluer doit-elle
s'améliorer peut-être on vous posera la
question dans un instant à lors des
états généraux de la justice doivent
s'ouvrir à l'automne mais l'actualité
judiciaire du moment c'est aussi le
début du procès des attentats du 13
novembre 2015 il a débuté depuis plus
d'une semaine devant la cour d'assises
spécialement composée de paris une
audience criminelle hors norme 140 jours
d'audience 20 accusés environ 1800
parties civiles plus de 330 avocat 542
tonnes de procédure quel regard vous
portez sur ce process mais j'ai deux
regards en fait un regard de citoyenne
qui comme la plupart d'entre nous
pensons endroits où nous étions il ya
quelques années au moment où ces faits
abominables se sont produits et je suis
heureuse que la justice entre en ligne
de mire maintenant en ligne de course
puis j'ai un regard plus professionnel
j'ai
appartenu pendant plusieurs années à la
aux assises de paris donc je sais le
travail que ça représente j'ai une
pensée pour toutes celles et ceux qui
ont travaillé pour que ça puisse se
dérouler les collègues les
fonctionnaires toutes les personnes qui
sont mobilisées par ce procès et bien
sûr tous ceux qui vont y participer par
ce qu'ils ont vécu dans leur chair ou
celle de leurs proches et jeu je sais
que ce sera difficile parce que redire
c'est revivre avec une centaine de
témoins aussi citées pour ce procès qui
donc va se dérouler pendant neuf mois
alors je le disais il ya des états
généraux de la justice qui doivent
s'ouvrir à l'automne c'est en tout cas
un communiqué de l'elysée qui les a
acquis les a annoncé 1 le 5 juin dernier
alors c'est l'occasion pour nous de
faire le point aussi sur la formation
des métiers de la justice en france par
exemple 11 écoles d'avocats dispose
d'une formation initiale notamment les
d'accès à la haute école des avocats
conseils de viroflay après un an et demi
de formation les élèves passent le
certificat d'aptitude à la profession
d'avocat et nicolas landry s'est rendu
dans cet établissement le jour des
examens oraux regardez c'est le jour j
pour les ad mulder élèves à la haute
école des avocats conseils de viroflay
elle se présente aujourd'hui à l'oral du
certificat d'aptitude à la profession
d'avocat
le cap à une épreuve de déontologie
suivi des soutenances du stage en
cabinet et du projet individuel face à
un jury de professionnels on classe le
candidat fascine situation concrète de
questionnements des montots logique et
on cherche à savoir s'il a bien acquis
les principes de notre métier ces
principes les ad mulder les a appris en
six mois durant cette période les élèves
sont formés à la pratique du métier
d'avocat ou encore au management d'un
cabinet suivent ensuite douze mois de
stage 6 mois en cabinet d'avocats et une
deuxième période de projets individuels
juridique en partenariat avec une
structure au total la formation dure 18
mois en vain les calades avocat je
m'attendais justement apprendre vraiment
comment me comporter en tant qu'avocat
quels sont justement toutes les
obligations
déontologiques qui s'impose à l'avocat
pour sanctionner cette formation le capa
est composé de deux épreuves écrites la
rédaction d'un acte et d'une
consultation juridique d'épreuves orales
la déontologie la soutenance et
l'incontournable plaidoirie au total 420
heures sont dispensés à les dac
le moyen de convaincre d'avoir cette
force de conviction qui va permettre
d'être une aide à la décision du juge
nous et les avocats font 240 heures en
plus du programme a posé par le conseil
national des barreaux ce qu'il faut
accentuer me semble-t-il c'est ce que
nous faisons déjà un petit peu hâlé dac
avec la création des modules approfondie
de pratiques professionnelles et les
différents diplômes et cursus
supplémentaire que nous avons créé il
faut impérativement que nous mettions
nos élèves vocaux en situation
d'immersion de mise en situation de
pratique professionnelle les prêts
spécialisé à leur avenir au sein de la
haute école des avocats conseils de
viroflay plus de 400 élèves avocats sont
formés en moyenne chaque année
voilà pour les avocats si on place le
curseur désormais sur les magistrats
maryvonne caillibotte comment se sont
ils formés d une école en france c'est
l'école nationale de magistrature
ce morcellement l'école est à bordeaux
c'est l'école mère en quelque sorte et
il ya une antenne sur l'île de la cité à
paris alors comment se déroule justement
la formation des magistrats moi c'est
une formation sur 31 mois donc qui est
assez longue et qui contient qui
contient plusieurs séquences on va dire
à la fois une formation initiale
théorique de plus de 30 mois une
formation sur le terrain en qualité
d'auditeur de justice donc dans des
juridictions où on passe dans toutes les
fonctions et où les éditeurs sont pris
en charge par des magistrats
professionnels déjà en poche et donc qui
aide à leur rôle à leur formation y
at-il selon vous des aspects qu'il
faudrait peut-être améliorer dans ces
formations formation de magistrats à la
formation des magistrats est
spécifiquement l'école la magistrature
est en mouvement perpétuel et d'ailleurs
si on n'était pas tout seul on est
constamment impacté notamment par tout
le débat actuel sur potentiellement la
suppression de l'école nationale de la
magistrature le nm qui seraient fondues
avec d'autres écoles donc c'est une
recherche permanente d'amélioration et
de façon à assurer une formation
juridique bien sûr mais aussi des
magistrats qui sont bien ancrés dans
leur temps et dans la société alors
revenons à ces états généraux de la
justice qui doit s'ouvrir normalement à
l'automne leur contour leur contenu pour
le moment sont assez flous ans depuis ce
communiqué de presse de l'elysée du 5
juin dernier y at il une énorme attente
de votre par maryvonne caillibotte au
final vous attendez d'en savoir plus
autour de ces états généraux
voilà une question de méthodologie
d'abord effectivement qui nous aidera
certainement à nous positionner les uns
les autres juridictions où même les
organisations syndicales qui ont
commencé déjà à réfléchir et d'après ce
que j'ai pu lire à manifester un certain
nombre d'attentes auprès de la
chancellerie donc la méthode nous dira à
nos cours durera un petit peu vers la
meilleure manière de de proposer ou
d'émettre les idées les souhaits les
critiques toutes choses effectivement
que nous avons toujours un peu en
magasin les propositions les idées et
puis nos espoirs si peut-être mais c'est
une actualité dans un contexte de remise
en cause de la justice un critique de
l'institution après peut citer la sphère
sara lee mis aussi le verdict dans le
procès en appel dans la sphère des
policiers brûlé à à viry châtillon en
essonne y avait cette phrase notamment
qui avaient fusé à lors d'une
manifestation de policiers le problème
de la police c'est la justice il ya une
urgence à sortir de ce temps et
peut-être à dessiner ce à quoi pourrait
ressembler la justice de demain le
problème de la police et la police et
nous en sommes les témoins d'ailleurs du
quotidien nous la justice et nous les
soutenons d'ailleurs dans les problèmes
et
l'émergence de leurs problèmes et la
manière dont nous on pense que si un
certain nombre de difficultés au sein de
la police était réglé ne serait-ce que
la formation le nombre de policiers
leurs équipements etc donc nous sommes
en fait à leurs côtés donc c'était une
opposition qui était assez artificiel et
très partiales il n'y a pas de
finalement prendre parti il faut
travailler ensemble c'est ce que vous
dites il y assure non seulement il faut
travailler ensemble et de fait nous
travailler ensemble notamment sur la
chaîne pénale puisque la fabrication de
la procédure et qui ensuite arrive
devant les juridictions effectivement
constitue cette espèce de deux chaînes
notamment sur l'aspect qualitatif que
nous devons travailler ensemble en ces
états généraux vous le dites la
méthodologie doit être encore défini
mais pourrait penser réfléchir à ce à
quoi la justice pourrait ressembler
demain vous la voyez comment la justice
de demain justement on pourrait y passer
toute la journée si je vous disais à
quoi je on a quelques items quand même
qu'ils ont commencé à percer notamment
paradoxalement au travers de bovo de la
sécurité puisque président de la
république s'est exprimé et si vous vous
écoutez bien ce qu'il a dit c'est que
c'est premier item concernait la réforme
de la procédure pénale notamment et donc
il a fixé une petite feuille de route
semble-t-il au ministre de la justice
qui va peut-être se retourner vers nous
dans le cadre des états généraux de la
de de la justice avec une lucide
peut-être plus unie ou magistrats
avocats travailler davantage ensemble
écoutez à ce propos maryvonne
caillibotte ce que pense le directeur de
l'ehs dakhla la haute école des avocats
de conseil à viroflay
l'avocat est un auxiliaire de justice je
préfère dire partenaires de justice et
nous avons chacun magistrats et avocats
en complément les uns des autres chacun
dans notre eau chacun dans notre
fonction mais dans l'intérêt d'une bonne
justice de justice rendues et qui puisse
être compris par le justiciable
travailler davantage ensemble on l'a
compris comment procède-t-on envie de
vous dire hors jeu j'ai la chance de
codiriger une juridiction où je croise
est ce pas ce travail partagé existe
vraiment entre le barreau de versailles
et puis la juridiction de versailles
donc c'est quelque chose qu'on vit au
quotidien les associés énormément donc
je ne dis pas que c'est un modèle en
tout cas c'est un exemple et ce n'est
pas le seul de la manière dont ça peut
très bien se passer dans le respect des
attributions des uns des autres ça c'est
sûr et certain j'ai toujours dit et
notamment pour la matière pénale que
plus la défense est à un niveau élevé et
plus elles élèvent aussi la juridiction
les parquetiers où les juges les
magistrats du siège donc on a
effectivement beaucoup de choses en
commun déjà pour commencer le code pénal
par exemple le code de procédure pénale
c'est le même une éthique qui n'est pas
tout à fait les mêmes et les avocats
comme nous prêtons serment un jour au
tout début de notre carrière et ça doit
rester un phare pour n'oublie de temps
en temps parce que les années sont pile
les épreuves et puis on s'éloigne un
petit peu de la pureté des principes et
pourtant ça devrait toujours nous l'idée
une dernière question sur cette justice
de demain le 30 août dernier le ministre
de la justice et garde des sceaux et
eric dupond moretti était à poissy pour
parler des ti vct ces travaux d'intérêt
général alternatives à l'incarcération
quel rôle qui à l'utilisation
peut-on avoir ses tiges dans la justice
de demain justement pour et bien avoir
cette alternative altercation à
l'altercation à l'incarcération pardon
effectivement le ministre était à poissy
mais je tiens à souligner que le tout
début de son déplacement était au
tribunal judiciaire il a commencé par
nous rendre visite qui est effectivement
je dirais la moindre des choses mais qui
est cohérent et donc au sein de la
juridiction nous avons évoqué le tiges
c'est le tiges c'est un monsieur d'âge
mûr ce qu'il ya c'est qu'il faut le
rendre plus plus présents n'ont pas
massif parce que c'est quand même une
peine extrêmement individualisé qui
correspond à un certain type de personne
et avec des conditions qu'il faut
remplir donc c'est un outil très
intéressant très important et qu'il faut
développer notamment dans le cadre de la
récidive ou de l'empêchement de la
récidive il ya beaucoup d'espoir à
continuer de mettre sur le tiche merci
maryvonne caillibotte d'être venu en
plateau je rappelle le procureur de la
république de versailles
[Musique]
alors que les journées du patrimoine se
déroulent ce week-end les villes des
poneys de mézières sur seine ont choisi
de mettre en avant un autre patrimoine
est les forces de l'ordre pour les
rapprocher de la population les deux
communes organisent ce 18 septembre
procès paul meyer une journée inédite et
gratuite autour de la sécurité un
village d'animations et de
démonstrations sportives s'installera à
la salle du bout du monde d'epône
regardez cette interview express
[Musique]
ox et pot de maizière c'est une
manifestation qui lui a pour but de
créer du lien entre la police et la
population
mais pas seulement c'est une
manifestation qui a vocation par faire
connaître un peu mieux le les métiers de
la sécurité en général pour permettre un
contact un petit peu différent de ce qui
se passe au quotidien avec la police en
particulier
il ya des stéréotypes un petit peu de la
police qui est tous souvent une police
répressive et qui est éloigné un petit
peu des quartiers
ce n'est plus la police de proximité
d'autres fois hélas le fait de créer ce
type d'événement permet de recréer de
voir la police pour tout un chacun sous
un aspect un petit peu différent
alors c'est des ateliers ludiques et des
ateliers de démonstration il y aura par
exemple des initiations aux jeux aux
sports de combat et aux gestes
techniques d'intervention de la police
vers la brigade académie qui est une
association créée par notre police
municipale
il y aura des démonstrations de savoir
faire des forces de sécurité avec des
techniques d'interpellation des
démonstration cynophile des
démonstrations équestres des secours à
la personne de la découverte du matériel
et des véhicules d'intervention et la
possibilité aussi d'avoir un survol d'un
hélicoptère du site et d'avoir un petit
baptêmes d'hélicoptère à un prix tout à
fait raisonnable ça permet de découvrir
aussi sous un autre angle comme on
découvre là la police sous un autre
angle mais aussi découvrir son cadre de
vie sous un autre angle que ce qu'on
voit tous les jours chaque année 1149
postiers sillonne les routes des
yvelines pour distribuer les lettres et
colis en tout genre le photographe et
reporter il ya un arthus-bertrand a
décidé de rendre hommage à ces femmes et
ces hommes en bleu et jaune en lançant
un projet jamais vu les facteurs qui
l'acceptent peuvent prendre en photo
leurs habitants emblématiques de leur
tournée le reportage de céline charles
il est 14h30 à la poste marly le roy et
claude s'engage dans une tournée
particulière aujourd'hui il ne faudra
pas que distribuer le courrier à ses
clients il va aussi les prendre en photo
cela fait un an que claude est facteur
et pourtant comme beaucoup d'autres il
connaît déjà tous les habitants des rues
qu'il arpente quotidiennement alors face
à cette proximité il ya un arthus
bertrand et la poste ont invité tous les
facteurs de france a photographié les
français qui les touche dans le cadre de
leur tournée
claude n'a pas hésité à participer c'est
la première fois que l'on propose à des
facteurs de prendre effectivement un
appareil photo de pouvoir rentrer
quelque part dans cette intimité que la
plupart des français ne voient pas c'est
à dire de s'intéresser aux gens de les
prendre en photo et de leur poser des
questions et au delà du métier que nous
avons et que nous aimons c'est pour nous
un véritable panorama pour vous de
découvrir comment nous sommes au
quotidien toujours le sourire aux lèvres
il tire le portrait des différentes
personnes qu'ils rencontrent toutes
heureuses de se prêter au jeu l'occasion
aussi d'en apprendre un peu plus sur ces
visages qu'il côtoie quotidiennement
qu'est ce que tu aimerais avoir changé
en france
c'est aussi la très large actuellement
au jour d'aujourd'hui ce que j'aimerais
voir
c'est plutôt une baisse de l'intolérance
en facteur je le croise tous les jours
et donc c'est vraiment une relation
personnelle avec lui il me connaît on se
connaît la relation de proximité est
importante parce que on ne peut que
mieux servir son client quand on connait
je peux avoir des personnes qui ont des
recommandés avec des bonnes des
mauvaises nouvelles mais le facteur est
le facteur toujours souriant un lien
unique qui ni une profession humaines et
celles et ceux qu'ils inspirent ou les
me mets moi je suis facteur et tous mes
clients je les aime les photos
recueillies seront présentés à travers
une exposition digital d'ici la fin 2021
et les plus belles photos seront
exposées à la poste du louvre l'année
prochaine il est le seul français dans
cette liste établie par le times il est
yvelinois omar sy figurent parmi les 100
personnalités les plus influentes du
monde selon le célèbre magazine
américain ses côtés dans ce palmarès le
spectre assez large est de scarlett
johansson à joe biden en passant par
lille n'a 6 ou encore elon musk l acteur
originaire de trappes a été à la pige de
la série et lupin qui a connu un succès
mondial en 2021 s'il est une chose à
retenir c'est sa gentillesse qui vous
apprennent et imprègne l'espace quand
vous êtes avec lui écrit l acteur et
réalisateur bradley cooper à propos
d'omar sy qui signe un court texte dans
le times à propos est bien de cette
nomination un film choc en avant
première ce vendredi à l'ugc vélizy une
fois que tu sais est un documentaire
écrit et réalisé par emmanuel kaeppelin
en collaboration avec anne marie sangla
récit sur le réchauffement climatique
menée à travers plusieurs rencontres
avec différents scientifiques du monde
entier nicolas d'andré
les études scientifiques parlait de
pénurie énergétique
d'emballement climatique
d'extinction le vivant
c'est un véritable choc un
bouleversement après avoir vu le film
documentaire une fois que tu sais des
questions se posent des inquiétudes
émergent souvent les gens sont pas bien
voilà mais je dirais que ça dépend un
petit peu d'où on en est par rapport à
la conscience de ce qui nous attend en
fait se dire aussi que on a dépassé les
bornes fait qu'on est allé trop loin et
qui a plus de retour en arrière possible
c'est ça en fait qui rend mal à l'aise
et qui rend très très mal en fait les
raisons de ces ressentis le récit de
l'auteur et réalisateur emmanuel
kaeppelin le spectateur est plongé dans
son esprit l'évolution de sa pensée sur
les sujets du réchauffement climatique
et de la préservation de l'environnement
on parle de ce moment là où vivent un
choc émotionnel énorme qui va vivre
quand tu y vas pour une raison
professionnelle être à bord d'un porte
containers et où il va avoir une vision
complètement apocalyptique de ce qui est
en train de nous arriver et moi je vais
accompagner pendant plusieurs années sur
la mise en forme de ce film deux ans et
demi de montage après cinq années de
tournage des séquences enregistrées
entre l'europe les états unis et le
bangladesh à la rencontre des
scientifiques et des spécialistes du
climat et experts du giec les ingénieurs
qui sont là pour en parler rich weinberg
qui est là pour parler de la fin des
énergies fossiles aussi qui est
spécialiste des énergies fossiles et des
villes en transition ils sont là pour
poser ce constat ce film a reçu
plusieurs reconnaissances dans plusieurs
festivals internationaux chaque
projection est suivie d'une discussion
participative avec les spectateurs puis
un guide est distribué à la fin pour
rassurer et tenter d'agir face aux
conséquences du changement climatique
une fois qu'on sait
qu'est-ce qu'on fait collectivement
[Musique]
avant de vous laisser l'association
manic oise le cinoche l'os lance sa
saison ne va pas en faire tout un cinéma
si justement c'est le nom de cette
saison à qui évoque forcément la
situation sanitaire l'équipe vous invite
pour une séance de cinéma ce vendredi à
20h à l'estaminet de magny les hameaux
au programme les productions l'année
dernière reportage fiction et découvert
des projets de l'association cette
soirée ouverte à tous sera également
l'occasion de présenter les temps forts
de la saison à venir soirée horreur une
nuit du cinéma écouter le fondateur de
l'association interrogé par justine
brasil décidé de nourrir avec des
créations donc c'est des choses qui ne
sont pas vues qui sont inédites
et puis ça permet de relancer de
communiquer toute la saison qui va venir
qu'on espère qu'on va tenir cette année
et qui va s'appeler ne va pas en faire
tout un cinéma si quelqu'un est curieux
de savoir comment on peut faire du
cinéma avec pas forcément des grandes
caméra derrière bref une vraie
production c'est le meilleur moyen de
venir découvrir les productions avec les
moyens on va dire du bord avec des
petites caméras voire même du g2 des
téléphones portables parce qu'on filme
aussi aux téléphones portables voilà
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi demain vendredi place aux
7,8 week-end pour bien terminer la
semaine dans les yvelines entre
actualité et loisirs belle semaine sur
tv 78
[Musique]